Hello everybody Ashley here and we will be discussing genetic testing.
Why do genetic testing?
Well, you can reveal your current health status.
It can give you answers possibly to some symptoms you don't have an answer to.
It can help you prevent future health problems and expose to you some predispositions.
It can also give you a glance of what you can pass down to your kids and maybe what they
might be facing in their future.
So depending on which genetic kit you do, you can get approximately 600,000 to 900,000
SNPs.
Your genetic report goes over so many pathways.
To highlight a few, we do look at the gut health and how your body works as a whole digestive
system.
We look at the liver detoxification and your detox pathways.
There are several of them and they all deal with different things.
We also look at how well your genetics can fight against oxidation.
We look at your brain chemistry and balance and really focus on the neurotransmitter pathway.
We look at how well your body is methylating and repairing its DNA.
We also look at the antioxidant production and with that the recycling piece as well.
And then the ammonia and sulfide clearance and vitamin D production.
Again, these are just highlighting a few of the pathways that we go over in a genetic
review and we cover so much more.
What do you get out of this?
You get a personalized nutrition and lifestyle recommendation plan.
This is going to focus specifically on your genetic makeup and you as an individual.
You may even get some answers that you didn't even know were even possible of getting because
they were in your genes, so matching up with the symptoms that you may be experiencing.
And the coolest part is you get to learn about your own DNA and why you are the way that
you are.
You can take your dirty genes and start cleaning them so you can start living to your full potential.
You can contact Conor's Clinic for more information or visit Conor's Clinic dot com to also touch
base on some more genetic videos or genetic information at all, especially if you want to get
started with a genetic review.
Thank you.